yeah hello and welcome to this video
this video is real mix back and it's
mostly about in use and new developments
that I would like to share with you the
first one is very very current um there
is a really good chess podcast the
perpetual chess podcast it's now it
turns three I think in the next couple
of weeks and I've been on the podcast in
one of the earliest episodes I think
episode six or seven and in fact I am
this week's guest yet a second time so
the perpetual chance podcast features me
an interview of about 90 minutes I think
about current projects and all kinds of
things you can read it up here on the
webpage of the perpetual chat podcast
and of course you can listen to it via
various platforms you can listen to it
here right on the web page but I think
it is also under yeah the usual suspect
said say Apple podcasts and probably
Google has something as well I'm not
quite that up-to-date there but if you
go to the perpetual chat postcards
website you will get there so if you
want to listen to me talk about all
kinds of things this is your opportunity
um then I wanted to mention that um
there's of course this is the Black
Friday week and it's something that I
already mentioned during one of my blitz
sessions there are huge discounts on
chasuble and all of my yeah more current
courses I have got two older ones these
are not on sale but all the current ones
are on sale and I'd like you to
encourage back to encourage you to check
them out if you always wanted to get
them this is now a good opportunity if
I'd like Magnus you still discounted my
karana repertoires discounted keep it
simple
efore indie forum is also cheaper and
the lifetime repertoire names Rogozin
is also cheaper this is under Daniel
bearishness label because we can only
have one author and Chester but this is
the corporation that I did together with
Daniel and I do the videos for this one
in particular note that the video
pricing is severely reduced so if you've
always wanted to have the videos for the
e4 cause the d4 course whatever it is or
Magnus's cause of course Magnus is cause
of course it sounds good
so this is still an opportunity I think
it's up to Friday that we have the
discounted prices the next one and this
is about print book my keep it simple d4
is now available in print so if you go
to the new NHS website and you go under
what's new here it is keep it simple one
d4 in green yeah nice one um yeah this
is currently I think up here on the new
NHS website to order however I would
like to mention that is important if you
want signed copies I'm sorry I'm
providing again signed copies of the
book from a German customers via a
friend of mine he's got a main order
book business we already did that last
year with the keep it simple efore book
and he has not yet gotten he didn't yet
get the copies as a matter of one or two
days i guess um that he gets them and
then i will drive over to his place sign
a couple of books and then if you want a
signed copy i'll give you more
information once they are really
available with the links and so on but
the book is out if you don't really care
about a signed copy just want a regular
one you can order it from you and share
so i think other sources you will figure
it out um and the final thing which is
nothing really out of the ordinary but
still something that I wanted to mention
of course I do weekly shows on chests 24
and I think if you look at the view
counts there the live shows they could
use more people being there
simply I mean I see that many people
watch them afterwards like they watch
them the archives are the same but it's
always cool to have people participate
in the chat and so on so make sure to
check out my live shows I actually
created a little bit of an overview
there there there are a couple of live
shows coming up just in the next couple
of days and let me just screwing it up
the first one is English
it's that Wednesday November 27 it's a
late night time late night show German
time 10:30 and evening and the second
English one will be at 6:00 in the
evening on Sunday and the German shows
on Friday at 6:00 and evening and Sunday
4:30 4:30 in the afternoon so there are
a total of six hours of live shows three
hours in German three hours in English
scheduled in the next couple of days the
sunday shows a little bit out of the
ordinary the reason is that next week
I'm going to travel to London form in
total four days and going there for a
chasuble meeting but also maybe I have a
look at some play in the Grinch has to a
final ever actually get tickets I have
no clue how they do that mostly
therefore for the chess about event but
maybe I get to see some of the the good
guys play so if you want to watch the
Ben tablet shows um these are the dates
and how do you get there yeah it's it's
fairly simple you can go by a YouTube
you can check the chess 24 and chess 24
German YouTube channel or you go on to
chess 24 itself and you don't even
actually need an account it's just
possible without you just go on half the
German version heads probably watch and
then you have live shows and then you
get on the left hand side and overview
of all the live shows that have been on
last couple of days or the ones that are
scheduled and you get all the ones with
me and if you have a chance to any for
account you can participate also in the
chat I haven't put on the now
Smith videos all that much in the last
couple of weeks um but it was kind of
noticeable that there were less people
coming and I think it's just good to
keep in touch on a live platform so you
can easily go through the chest 24
website or yeah subscribe to chest 24
and chest 24 German on YouTube it's also
a good way to get all the announcement
of scheduled shows so yeah many things
to share I hope something amongst those
information is useful to you be it yeah
benefiting from the videos could use the
course prices or the book or whatever it
is or you want to watch a show many
things are possible
also the perpetual chance podcast is
really great by the way it's not just
like I'm on it it's good this is why I'm
mentioning it but I think Ben now has
over 150 episodes on let me just check
let me just check I should go go to
browser actually I'm 153 so he's got
more than 150 episodes with Ches podcast
interviews and he's got all great people
I gotta come ski or took Markov and many
many interesting players and and chess
personalities to to listen to it's
really good so yeah make sure to check
out the the point is that I gave you
thanks a lot for watching